ladies and gentlemen my name is  Professor Philip Goodman my job is to  explain the unexplainable untangle the  truth from the fiction you don't have to  have your life ruled by superstitious  fear everything you spent a lifetime  trying to debunk the supernatural it's  all three cases I couldn't explain you  go and investigate if you did things are  not always as they seem  tell me about your incident  you don't believe here hello  I don't people looking me thinking  they're mad because I know what song do  you believe in evil professor I didn't  until that night Maria these are Saints  I know you're still there the spirit I  understand how easy it is to get  confused and then in force get into your  head mind everything is exactly as it  seems you don't know everything the  brain sees what it wants to sit  [Music]  you